depuis une semaine le mouvement de
protestation libanais ne cesse de
croître
près du tiers de la population de ce
pays de cinq millions d'habitants envahi
les rues des villes de toutes les
régions
du jamais vu chrétiens sunnites et
chiites semble pour une fois sur la même
longueur d'onde
cette enseignante dit que toute la
population souffre c'est ce qui nous
rassemble dit elle les dirigeants ont
réussi à nous unir contre eux alors on
joue dit cette dame explique que le
mécontentement général est surtout
causée par la corruption des dirigeants
politiques
quelle que soit leur appartenance
religieuse la contestation a été
déclenchée par l'annoncé le 17 octobre
de nouvelles taxes sur certains produits
de consommation et surtout sur les
appels via la populaire messagerie
whatsapp c'est un coup de trop a fait
exploser la colère dans un pays où des
besoins élémentaires comme l'eau
l'électricité et l'accès aux soins de
santé ne sont pas assurés
les nouvelles taxes ont été annulés mais
la colère populaire n'a pas baissé le
soulèvement populaire a pris une
nouvelle tournure mercredi avec
l'apparition en masse de l'armée autour
de beyrouth
malgré des face à face parfois tendue
les manifestants ont pu poursuivre leur
activité
les militaires encore très respectée
dans le pays n'ont pas utilisé la force
pour les déloger d'un hôtel allemand
attend ces mines où elle m'entendra
après une semaine de silence le
président michel aoun a tenté
aujourd'hui de calmer le jeu ou nessma
maintenant les comptes année dans je
suis prêt à rencontrer vos représentants
pour entendre vous demande a dit le
président en ajoutant que ce n'était pas
à la rue de faire chuter le régime en
place
les manifestants n'ont pas apprécié cet
homme dit que les revendications de la
rue sont claires d'abord la démission
des dirigeants politiques
le dialogue viendra après je reste dans
la rue dit cette femme je veux récupérer
mes droits finir mes études
universitaires y trouver du travail ici
pas à l'étranger
le gouvernement a annoncé en début de
semaine de nouvelles réformes
économiques mais rien n'y fait les
banques les écoles et les universités
sont fermées jusqu'à nouvel ordre
trente ans après la fin de la guerre
civile le liban est à nouveau paralysé
sylvain le jardin radio canada montréal